[Music]
blue and welcome to this video this is
some one of the most important chapters
of this course and it's about the names
of Indian with four Queen c2 let's put
the starting position on the board so we
have the nihms oh and Queen c2
why is this so important the main reason
is that this is the most frequently
played move and it is also the most
frequently played move on all levels of
play this is often an important
distinction to make
sometimes you see a line on the very top
level and you say oh yeah and it looks
to be the main line they all play it but
it's never seen on the club level or
typical yeah tournament sense that you
would play um an example for that for
example is the Berlin defence of them
the real dope s there's an opening
that's super important on the top level
but never seen in club chess people just
don't play it well if people allow the
nihms oh we need to is most frequently
seen there are different reasons for
that I think depending on the level of
play on the top level they like to play
Queen c2 because they want to Bishop am
and want that without any concession
they're not necessarily afraid of the
double pawn let's say and would also
play III for example not fearing a
capture but on the club level many
players simply want to avoid the double
opponent or a course and think okay
Queen c2 is a way to do that them up
side of Queen c2 is definitely this
particular aspect you won't get the
double pawn the downside and it has a
clear downside is it takes a bit of time
the Queen moves early on on move four
and will spend another move to recapture
on c3 and almost all variations and then
the Queen will often be somewhat exposed
on c3 so why does trading time for
structural integrity and the bishop am
that means we have to be white um
clear about our own goals we cannot just
give up the bishop pam-4 no structural
compensation or some other compensation
and our compensation here has to be
development so we want to open up the
position quickly and trying to prove
that white lost too much time yeah in
the process of getting the bishop Pam um
with our repertoire approach of
combining the names oh and the Rogozin
you would expect a d5 based answer -
Quincy - and in fact our reply is
exactly that however we are not opting
for the immediate d5 in this position
those two moves castles that is our
recommendation and d5 they can lead to
the same position um if you play d5 and
white plays a3 which is one of the main
continuations then castles would lead to
a position that is some quite a
cornerstone of our recommendation we
reach this position after castles
eighty-three takes takes and d5 so there
are two ways to this position the main
difference between the two is that after
the immediate d5 going back to this
white can also take and this leads us to
entirely different types of positions
after takes mean takes is a possibility
but completely different to all other
variations that we have in the
repertoire after Bishop g5 this looks a
little bit like a recursion but the
difference is that there is no knight on
f3 and this is a distinct difference
this is not a terrible line for black
but we thought that in comparison it
makes more sense to cancel first and go
to them to the main line in a different
move order what you allow with castling
that is an important thing to recognize
that white now
does not have to play three but has some
alternatives like Knight f3 or reform so
there's a difference in those in both
both lines d5 and castles what you allow
what you prevent it's a bit of yeah it's
a bit of a trade-off that same we need
to mention though that if you learn
castles according to this repertoire the
mainline might also rise from 45 so this
is an easy later addition to your
repertoire if you like so um you just
have to learn a couple of side lines
against 45 to make this work as well so
after Queen c2
our recommendation is to castle now the
overwhelming main move this was a real
preview of our entire one d4 course
based on the nimzo-indian end recording
available on chess about calm thanks for
watching and see you soon
[Music]